صاروخ كوري شمال يفجر الردود فعل دوليه
متسارعه مواقف جاءت فور اطلاق كوريا
الشماليه مره اخرى صاروخا باليسيا عابرا
للقارات سقط على بعد 200 كيلو متر قباله
سواحل اليابان وفقا للجيش الكوري الجنوبي
هو الاحدث في سلسله قياسيه من عمليات
الاطلاق الصاروخيه خلال الاسابيع الاخيره
الولايات المتحده ادانت بشده اطلاق
الصاروخ واعلنت انها ستتخذ كافه الاجراءات
اللازمه لضمان كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان في
حين تعاقد نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كاملا
حارس اجتماعا طارقا على هامشي قمه منتدى
التعاون الاقتصادي لاسيا والمحيط الهادئ
في بانكوك مع قاده اليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه واستراليا ونيوزلندا وكندا لبحث
تداعيات العمليه كما اعلن مسؤول في البيت
الابيض
من قبل كوريا الشماليه انتهاكا لع من
قرارات الامم المتحده الامنيه انه يزعزع
الامن في المنطقه ويثير التوترات غير
الضروريه اننا ندين بشده هذه الاعمال
وندعو كوريا الشماليه الى وقف تلك الاعمال
غير القانونيه المزعزيعه للاستقرار اما
رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه فدعا الى فرض عقوبات
على كوريا الشماليه واعلن عن تعزيز وضع
الدفاع المشترك مع الولايات المتحده معلقا
ان بلاده تنفق مع المجتمع الدولي لما وصفه
بكبح جماح
السابقه
كنز العديد من قرارات مجلس الامن وتهديدا
كبيرا للسلام والاستقرار لشبه جزيره
الكوريه ومنطقه اسيا والعالم اجمع
اليابان انه عمليه الاطلاق الصاروخيه غير
مقبوله اطلاقا من احتمال اطلاق كوريا
الشماليه مزيدا من الصواريخ
يشعروا الى انه وفي الاشهر الاخيره كشفت
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان من تعاونهم الامن ومن مناوراتهم
العسكريه المشتركه في مواجهه تهديدات
كوريا الشماليه المتزايد ملوك الشيخ
العربيه